[Musik]
der hat zehn sie
überall auf der welt
und gleicht
rund um die uhr
filmen kameras
packende
extrem ruhig bleibt ruhig
furchterregende
naturphänomene was sollen wir tun guck
dir das an man ist wie gelähmt
es gibt kein entkommen
das ist reality tv sie glauben sie
kennen das wetter diese experten
erklären was wirklich passiert das
wasser fließt in den wirbel mit
den spektakulärsten wetter videos der
welt
mit hilfe moderner technologie können
wir heute vieles kontrollieren die natur
aber nicht
wo sie zuschlägt kann sie landschaften
und leben für immer verändern
und das innerhalb von sekunden
er zeigt auf man sieht die drehung
zweiter märz 2012 in den usa steuert ein
heftiger tornado auf henry will in jena
zu
der tornado wurde noch stärker als er
die stadt erreichte mit böen bis zu 270
kilometern pro stunde kein spaß
der sturm nimmt kurs auf das
schulzentrum der stadt das über 1000
kinder und jugendliche besuchen wegen
des sturms schicken die lehrer ihre
schüler früher nach hause aber die
letzten busse schaffen es nicht mehr der
tornado ist schon zu nah die kinder
rennen zurück in das schulgebäude
minuten später erreicht der tornado die
schule
überwachungskameras rund um das gebäude
filmen den aufprall
wenn ein schulgebäude aus stahl und
stein so schnell auseinander genommen
wird muss es ein heftiger tornado sein
ist
im gebäude machen sich schüler und
lehrer auf das schlimmste gefasst
und dann
zeitgleich mit dem stromausfall ist der
tornado dort als würde eine bombe
einschlagen
ein lehrer sucht schutz in einem flur
man sieht wie er sich zusammen kommt und
sich die ohren zuhält der extreme
druckabfall drückt aufs trommelfell
sicher eine sehr beängstigende situation
die turnhalle ist bereits beschädigt
wenn der wind die wand ein drückt kann
die luft von unten das dach hochdrücken
und abreißen
in den großen offenen raum sieht man
lauter trümmer herum fliegen am besten
bleibt man in einem innen liegenden flur
in bodennähe so eine große turnhalle
kann zur todesfalle werden
in nicht einmal 20 sekunden wird die
schule völlig verwüstet aber wie durch
ein wunder bleiben schüler und lehrer
praktisch unverletzt sie sind in einem
büro vorne im gebäude untergekommen auch
die schulbusse werden nicht verschont
eine kamera im bus hat die schreckens
momente gefilmt der sturm hat den bus
erfasst und in ein restaurant auf der
anderen straßenseite geschleudert
er war total ramponiert alle fenster
zertrümmert und der motorraum abgerissen
henry will und umgebung werden von dem
heftigen tornado völlig verwüstet
elf menschen kommen ums leben hunderte
häuser werden zerstört
april 2011 ein tornado mit über 300
kilometer pro stunde
rotationsgeschwindigkeit
fegt über alabama hinweg
das war ein sehr zerstörerischer tornado
man erkennt gut die klassische trichter
form und die niedrige wolken basis
ich will filme wie er hier rum kommt
verhandeln ist der riesig
[Musik]
diese kraft ist unvorstellbar und die
wolkenformationen um den eigentlichen
tornado herum
da fliegen überall trümmer herum
in einem anderen teil der stadt nehmen
zwei männer auf der interstate im selben
tornado aus der nähe auf
[Musik]
das ist extrem gefährlich
so was sieht man nur einmal im leben
[Musik]
so sollte man nicht an den sturm
heranfahren
[Musik]
lass uns abhauen ich meine es ernst
er kommt über die straße da wo wir
gerade warm
wenn solche trümmerteile herum fliegen
ist das äußerst gefährlich
[Musik]
der tornado fegte über ein gebäude
hinweg und es explodierte förmlich die
bruchstücke wurden zugeschossen
überall riesige trümmerteile
ein holzklotz wird von dem wirbelsturm
herumgeschleudert wie ein projektil er
durch schlägt nicht nur fenster sondern
selbst autotür
[Musik]
ich erkenne hier nichts mehr wieder
alles sieht anders aus heuser
orientierungspunkte der zaun auf dem
heimweg alles weg wie eine andere welt
der tornado war teil einer serie von
über 350 tornados die vier tage gedauert
und 21 us-bundesstaaten heimgesucht hat
so etwas gibt es sehr selten
denn es müssen viele faktoren
zusammenkommen damit solche tornados
entstehen der tornado in alabama ist nur
einer von über 200 an diesem tag noch
nie hat man so viele tornados
gleichzeitig gezählt
testen sie ihr wissen über tornados
die meisten tornados auf der
nordhalbkugel rotieren gegen den
uhrzeigersinn während sich die meisten
auf der südhalbkugel mit dem
uhrzeigersinn drehen das liegt unter
anderem daran dass sich die erde um ihre
eigene achse dreht was die so genannte
corioliskraft erzeugt sie lenkt winde
auf der nord- und südhalbkugel in
entgegengesetzte richtungen dies
bestimmt dann auch die drehrichtung von
tiefdruckgebieten aus denen sich
tornados entwickeln
mai 2015 ein sonniger tag in florida
unweit des strandes von fort lauderdale
formt sich plötzlich eine wasserhose
[Musik]
das kann ziemlich bedrohlich werden
diese starken winde versetzen die
aufsteigende luft die immer schnellere
rotation
[Musik]
sieh dir was an die wasserhose erfasst
eine hüpfburg da sind kinder drauf
sie wird über die palmen und eine stark
befahrene straße gewirbelt
[Musik]
sie überschlägt sich einmal zwei mal und
wird dann vom wind hoch in die luft
getragen
die hüpfburg landet auf einem parkplatz
sie war zwar fest gebunden der
betonpfeiler hat im cern des windes aber
nicht standgehalten
[Musik]
vor wasserrosen muss man sich genauso
hüten wie vor tornados
man sollte zusehen dass man sich schnell
in sicherheit bringt
die drei kinder auf der hüpfburg wurden
hinausgeschleudert sie erlitten
knochenbrüche und kleinere verletzungen
und mussten ins krankenhaus
[Musik]
mehr als sieben millionen menschen
besuchen jedes jahr die kilometerlangen
malerischen strände von hawaii
februar 2011 zwei junge touristen
bewundern die brandung an der sharks sie
sind in wellen gefährlich nahe
augenzeugen sind beunruhigt
die müssen darunter
das ist raus vulkangestein es ist
äußerst gefährlich dort zu stehen wo die
wellen sich brechen
aber die beiden erkennen die gefahr
nicht plötzlich rollen mehrere hohe
wellen heran spülen sie über die felsen
und reißen sie in die tiefe
[Musik]
das wasser trifft mich wie ein schlag
die kraft solcher wassermassen darf man
niemals unterschätzt
[Musik]
wir nennen das die siebte welle in einer
gruppe von wellen ist immer mal eine
dabei die plötzlich doppelt so groß ist
wie die anderen
mann ein die eine große welle
überstanden zu haben aber dann kommt
eine hinterher die sich auf der ersten
aufbaut und sogar noch höher wird
die zwei touristen werden über die
scharfkantigen felsen geschleudert und
stehen unter schock der junge mann
scheint starke schmerzen zu haben er hat
sich was gebrochen sieht so aus
der helfer tut genau das richtige er
stabilisiert den jungen mann und hält
ihn über wasser bei so einem aufprall
auf gestein muss man mit einer
rückenverletzung rechnen
rettungskräfte treffen ein und bringen
die beiden ins krankenhaus lebensgefahr
besteht glücklicherweise nicht
wissen sie wie wellen entstehen
wenn der wind über das mehrweg traut die
luft reibung die oberfläche auf so dass
der wind mehr angriffsfläche hat und das
wasser auftürmen kann
das ist der beginn der wellenenergie je
länger also der wind aus derselben
richtung geht desto größer werden die
welt und wenn sich große wogen vereinen
können sie zu monsterwellen werden wie
diese fast 20 meter hohe wasserwand die
in der nordsee auf ein schiff prallt
von hoher see geht es jetzt in die wüste
von nevada
september 2014
nach hurrikan norbert überschwemmen
starke regenfälle im südwesten der usa
der verkehr auf dem highway nördlich von
las vegas kommt zum stehen denn riesige
schlammlawinen rollen plötzlich links
und rechts der fahrbahn entlang
wir sind mitten auf dem highway in
nevada solange keine autos vorbei
schwimmen ist alles okay
die das da
indem wellen sitzt ein rentnerehepaar um
die 70
ihr wagen wird von den fluten
mitgerissen
menschen am straßenrand suchen
händeringend nach einer möglichkeit zu
helfen
[Musik]
ein paar mutige leute wollten den beiden
helfen und sie aus dem auto befreien
einer ging tatsächlich los um riskierte
dabei sein eigenes leben
da schwimmt das auto und der typ wurde
gerade vom wasser verschluckt bot
der wählen und die drei menschen werden
von den fluten über die kante und auf
die darunter liegende fahrbahn gerissen
wie durch ein wunder wird dabei niemand
ernsthaft verletzt alle drei können
geborgen werden
ich fragte nur wie geht es meiner frau
und er sagte sie ist okay und ich meinte
sagen sie ihr dass es mir auch gut geht
unglaublich dass da jemand lebend
rausgekommen ist
[Musik]
ein monat zuvor ein anderer highway ein
ähnliches szenario
nördlich von las vegas droht eine
flutwelle zahlreiche autos mitzureißen
die gerade im stau stehen die wetter
bleibt mit den bergen hängen und bringen
sintflutartige regenfälle mit das wasser
fliesst bergab und verwandelt die büste
in nullkommanichts in reißende flüsse
die autos wegspülen
ein augenzeuge film das geschehen
plötzlich bemerkt er wie ein leeres auto
auf einen anderen wagen zusteuert in dem
ein älteres paar sitzt
sie versuchen sich aus der falle zu
befreien aber wie wegfahren können sie
nicht mehr und die anderen autos kommen
auf sie zu sie müssen gerettet werden
eine gruppe von soldaten entdeckt die
beiden und kommt ihnen zu hilfe die
männer eilen durch die fluten und bergen
das paar aus dem wagen
aber einer von ihnen verliert den halt
schon 15 cm wasser können einen umreißen
hat keinen halt mehr gefunden das ist
wie eine sehr starke unterströmung im
meer
einer seiner kameraden kann ihn jedoch
schnell aus dem wasser retten
glücklicherweise wird niemand verletzt
das sind die wahren helden menschen die
sich selbst in gefahr bringen um fremden
zu helfen
[Musik]
neunter april 2015 im norden von
illinois brown sich schwere unwetter mit
starken winden und hagelschauern
zusammen ein geschäftsreisen auf dem
highway sucht unter einer brücke schutz
da erblickt er etwas furcht einflößendes
einen tornado und er ist bereits
gefährlich nah
ich weiß nicht in welche richtung er
sich bewegt also wohin soll ich fliehen
er ist breit und riesig und dunkel und
scheint immer größer zu werden
wenn es aussieht als würde der tornado
größer werden kommt er wahrscheinlich
näher dann musst du schnell überlegen
wie du weg kommst er kommt direkt auf
mich zu
verdammt ich bin noch nie in einen
tornado geraten
wenn man nicht gerade ein erfahrener
sturmjäger ist weiß man nicht wohin
erzielt und davor weg zu laufen ist
nicht so einfach
der fahrer bleibt wo er ist und fängt
seltenen aufnahmen von dem tornado ein
der sich seinen weg über den highway
band
gruselig
der mann ist unter einer überführung ein
denkbar schlechter ort denn unter der
brücke beschleunigt der wind noch mehr
weil er durch die engstelle
man das ist total verrückt
kräftige windböen in floh genannt
strömen an der basis in den tornado ein
der truck wird heftig durchgerüttelt
fühlt sich an als würde der wagen gleich
abheben ernsthaft
war ja
die windgeschwindigkeit wächst
dramatisch je näher man dran ist 30 oder
60 metern er und sein auto wäre wohl
mitgerissen worden
unglaublich er hat den spiegel
umgeklappt beide spiegel
der mann hat glück und der tornado zieht
ab er hinterlässt eine 50 kilometer
lange schneise der verwüstung und
fordert zwei menschenleben es ist nur
einer von mehreren tornados die an
diesem tag hier durchziehen
[Musik]
nicht nur tornado sorgen für chaos auf
den straßen
dieser sattelschlepper gerät auf einem
highway in colorado in heftige sturmböen
[Musik]
der fahrer steuert abrupt in ein feld
und behält den truck gerade so unter
kontrolle
dieser fahrer verdient einen orden
unfassbar dass er sein fahrzeug im
letzten moment noch ausbalanciert
[Musik]
das ist wie bei einem segelboot er dreht
ab so dass weniger druck auf segel also
die seite des schleppers wirkt ein oder
zwei sekunden später und er wäre
umgekippt
[Musik]
wind kann fahrzeugen mit hohem
schwerpunkt schon bei 65 kilometer pro
stunde gefährlich werden darüber muss
man sich im klaren sein
[Musik]
aber wind kann nicht nur autos
gefährlich werden sondern auch der
straße selbst
1940 zerrten starke winde mit etwa 70
kilometern pro stunde an der die
kommandos brücke
wegen ihrer massiven bauweise verdrehte
der wind den fahrbahn träger bis er ins
wasser stürzte
glücklicherweise kam kein mensch zu
schaden
die ingenieure lernten aus dem einsturz
und bauten die brücke mit kind
durchlässigen fachwerk trägern wieder
auf sie ist noch heute in betrieb
september 2014
ein mann aus san diego wie gerade nach
hause fahren als plötzlich ein baum auf
ihn herab stürzt der 15 meter hohe
eukalyptus baum blockiert den gesamten
freeway und verfehlt den fahrer nur
knapp
erstaunlich dass der mann lediglich ein
paar kratzer abgekriegt hat
der blaue wagen des fahrers ist völlig
zerstört ebenso ein weiteres auto das
feuchte windige wetter geht auf hurrikan
odile zurück der am vortag auf die
mexikanische halbinsel baja california
traf
ein hurrikan bringt auch immer tropisch
feuchte luft mit sich all diese
feuchtigkeit zog in südkalifornien in
den erdboden wenn ein baum flaches
wurzelwerk hat und der boden auf einmal
sehr nass wird wird er instabil
kommt dann noch heftiger wind dazu kippt
der baum einfach um
naturgewalten können einen ganzen
landstrich in wenigen augenblicken in
ein katastrophengebiet verwandeln
verängstigt die touristen halten fest
wie im april 2015 ein erdbeben der
stärke 7,8 das libanesische bhaktapur
erschüttert
jahrhundertealte hindu-tempel erzittern
unter dem heftigen beben
[Musik]
man ist nirgendwo sicher um einen herum
stürzt alles ein bei so heftigen beben
verhält sich der erdboden fast als wäre
er flüssig dem hält kaum ein gebäude
stand
[Musik]
zwölf kilometer westlich und kathmandu
lässt das beben diesen stark befahrenen
kreisverkehr erzittern
man sieht wir alle auf die straße laufen
die menschen gehen von den gebäuden weg
denn die sind nicht besonders stabil und
können sehr schnell einstellt
die leute stolpern herum weil der
asphalt wellen schlägt
plötzlich stürzt ein denkmal auf die
straße und verfehlt nur knapp mehrere
autos
nach etwa 50 sekunden ist das beben
vorbei
sekunden das klingt immer kurz aber wenn
man mal mit zählt 123 bis rauf zu 50 und
stellt sich vor solange bebt die erde
unter einem dann ist das eine furchtbar
lange zeit
durch ein erdbeben wird einem bewusst
dass die erde aus dünnen schichten
besteht die indische platte schiebt sich
richtung norden auf die eurasische
platte zu dabei senkt sich die erste
platte mit einem riesigen druck um
mehrere zentimeter bis meter ab und
erzeugt so eines der heftigsten erdbeben
der welt
[Musik]
die verwüstung in der region ist immens
über 8000 menschen kommen ums leben mehr
als 15.000 werden verletzt
[Musik]
häuser und historische gebäude sind
unwiederbringlich zerstört
[Musik]
das ist katastrophal
es ist verheerend wenn das eigene haus
der tempel die heimatstadt zerstört sind
es dauert lange nach so einem ereignis
neue infrastruktur aufzubauen
[Musik]
ein regnerischer tag im dezember 2012 im
us bundesstaat washington ist ein
güterzug unterwegs was glauben sie wird
gleich passieren
eisenbahnwaggons werden wie spielzeug
herumgeworfen
da kommen schlamm steine und grünzeug
den berg runter sogar ein paar bäume man
stelle sich vor dort stünde ein mensch
den zug hat es von den schienen gehauen
im pazifischen nordwesten der usa kann
es zu dieser jahreszeit starke
regenfälle geben
der regen lässt die berghänge instabil
werden und wenn dieser zog dort häufig
vorbei fährt trägt die vibration noch
weiter dazu bei und all das zusammen
kann dann zu so einem erdrutsch wie
diesem führen
[Musik]
die
bugs gibt hält das tiefe wurzelwerk
alles zusammen aber dieser teil des
hangs war nicht gewachsen nichts hält
die erde dort fest da hat sich der ganze
schlamm auf die bahngleise ergossen
sieben waggons entgleisen durch den
erdrutsch glücklicherweise wird niemand
verletzt
schauen wir jetzt zum himmel
februar 2013 auto kameras in russland
zeichnen einen 10.000 tonnen meteo am
himmel auf
er kam völlig überraschend
seine flugbahn war so nahe der sonne
dass unsere detektoren ihn übersehen
haben
man fragt sich auch dass eine rakete
oder ein flugzeug ist man ist komplett
ahnungslos
das war sicher furchteinflößend man
sieht plötzlich etwas am himmel weiß
nicht was es ist wo es aufschlägt und
was als nächstes passieren wird
der feuerball zieht eine fast 500
kilometer lange spur hinter sich her
meteore bestehen teils aus gestein teils
aus eis in unserer atmosphäre entsteht
reibungshitze die das eis zu wasser
werden und dann verdampfen lässt und
daraus bestehen schließlich unsere
wolken
durch die hitze beim sturz durch die
atmosphäre
explodiert der meteor schließlich in
einem riesigen feuerball rund 20
kilometer über der erde
[Musik]
der feuerball leuchtet heller als die
sonne und erzeugt bei seiner explosion
eine heftige druckwelle
und wo kommen die schallwellen
man hört überall glassplitter menschen
geraten in panik weil sie nicht wissen
was los ist
das objekt kam mit so viel reibung und
geschwindigkeit durch die atmosphäre das
dabei enorme energie freigesetzt wurde
als der mieter explodierte entlud sich
diese energie in der druckwelle und die
traf mit enormer wucht auf fenster und
auf menschen
die meiste energie wird von der
atmosphäre absorbiert aber die
druckwelle lässt dächer einstürzen und
verletzt über 1000 menschen meist durch
umherfliegende glassplitter
was von dem meteoriten übrigblieb
erzeugte einen kaka mit gut sechs metern
durchmesser das war wohl nur ein
bruchteil des ursprünglichen meteors
der fall zeigt wie die erdatmosphäre uns
vor solchen objekten schützt die meisten
meteore verglühen durch die starke
reibung
dieser hatte eine ausreichende größe und
den richtigen eintrittswinkel um der
erde in nah genug zu kommen und solche
schäden anzurichten
[Applaus]
was wissen sie über meteore
gelegentlich werden mit theorie mit
bunten schleifen beobachtet sie
entstehen wenn gase in der atmosphäre
ionisiert werden so erscheint sauerstoff
beispielsweise grün auch metalle aus dem
meteor selbst wie eisen können in
spektakulären farben verglühen
ein vereister bergpass in norwegen ein
lkw ohne winterreifen ist liegen
geblieben ein abschleppwagen soll ihn
nun über den berg bringen
da werde ich ja schon vom zuschauen
nervös da wird ein lkw abgeschleppt und
der rutscht auf dieser verschneiten
straße hin und her
plötzlich rutscht der lkw über den
strassenrand und hängt mit seinem ganzen
gewicht in der leitplanke
sie gibt nach der lkw rollt zur seite
und zieht den abschlepper mit sich in
die tiefe in allerletzter sekunde bringt
sich der fahrer mit einem hechtsprung in
sicherheit
aber der zweite fahrer stürzt mit seinem
lkw 60 meter in die tiefe
der abschlepper hat schneeketten
daherkommt er den vereisten berg hoch
der lkw hat aber keine
und der ist so schwer und entwickelt so
viel wucht dass er nicht mehr
aufzuhalten ist als er in die leitplanke
gerutscht
[Musik]
die fahrzeuge sind zerstört aber der
fahrer überlebt glücklicherweise eine
ladung aus lachs und eis hat den sturz
abgefedert
statt erweckt es offenbar auch eine tüte
voll lachs ist der fisch beim sturz in
die fahrerkabine gerutscht und hat
schlimmere verletzungen verhindert
der fahrer wird mit lungen kollaps sowie
mehreren knochenbrüchen ins krankenhaus
eingeliefert
der erste weihnachtstag
2012 einige rodelvergnügen sich am
kalifornischen jackson liegt aber der
see ist nur zum teil zugefroren ein mann
schießt über die eisfläche hinaus ins
wasser
da
die körpertemperatur sinkt und man
riskiert eine unterkühlung mit jeder
minute im wasser steigt die lebensgefahr
umstehende eilen dabei aber als der
erste helfer an den dünnen rand der
eisfläche kommt gibt sie nach
augenblicke später stürzt schon der
nächste ins eisige wasser
jeder denkt sofort wir müssen die person
da rausholen aber das eis bricht immer
weiter ein jetzt muss nicht nur ein
mensch gerettet werden sondern gleich
mehrere
ein mann nimmt ein seil zu hilfe der
ansatz ist gut aber auch er steht auf
dünnem eis
man sieht wie sich wasser um seine füße
sammelt das vorher noch unter dem eis
war
irgendwas hat das eis gebrochen ich
tippe mal auf ihn und schon bricht er
auch ein und schafft eine neue öffnung
in der eisschicht
schließlich gelingt es helfern an land
die eingebrochenen bezahlen aus dem
wasser und auf festen boden zu ziehen
das wichtigste ist sofort die nassen
klamotten auszuziehen jetzt muss schnell
die körperkerntemperatur erhöht werden
insgesamt brachen rund ein dutzend
menschen ein aber niemand wurde
ernsthaft verletzt
roaming vergnügen sich schneemobil
fahrer auf der piste wenige tage zuvor
hatte ein sturm fast 60 zentimeter
neuschnee gebracht
[Musik]
ein mann fährt gerade richtung gipfel
als ich um ihn herum plötzlich der
schnee löst
[Musik]
diesen schneebrett ist mit eis
durchsetzt und es kommt den berg
herunter
die anderen schneemobile fahrer
versuchen den schneemassen auszuweichen
sie mussten sich selbst vor der lawine
in sicherheit bringen und dann schnell
ihrem freund helfen
wo ist er
die helfer müssen sich beeilen denn dem
verschütteten geht schnell die luft aus
und er erstickt
sie entdecken sein fahrzeug das aus dem
schnee ragt und dann auch seinen helm
legt die brust frei
ich bin okay
der war nahe an der oberfläche so
konnten sie erst mal seinen kopf
befreien und an platz um den brustkorb
herum schaffen damit er atmen konnte
das ist wie in zement festzustecken
bringt opel wird
unter diesen schneemassen kann man nicht
atmen und weiß nicht wo oben und unten
ist
obwohl ihn die lawine unter sich
begraben hat trägt der mann keinerlei
verletzungen davon
man kennt ja solche geschichten aber
wenn man eine echte lawine sieht bleibt
einem fast das herz stehen
wie gut kennen sie sich mit schnee aus
in weißem licht sind alle wellenlängen
oder farben des sichtbaren spektrums
enthalten schnee wirkt weiß weil die
vielen luftbläschen darin das licht
streuen und so das gesamte lichtspektrum
reflektieren mit eis verhält es sich
anders in juneau alaska liegen die
mendenhall eishöhlen ihre faszinierenden
blau schattierungen entstehen weil das
sauerstoffarme eis die verschiedenen
lichtfarben unterschiedlich stark
absorbiert rotes langwelliges licht am
meisten blaues kurzwelliges am wenigsten
so bleibt hinter einer dicken eisschicht
nur noch blaues licht übrig
in colorado soll ein feld kontrolliert
abbrennen es hat sich aber ein
sogenannter staub teufel gebildet der
dort heimische fische so genannte
steppen hexen durch die luft wirbelt
auch kontrollierte brände sind riskant
eine kleine veränderung der
wetterbedingungen und schon wird daraus
ein und kontrollierter brand
der gut 60 meter hohe staub teufel
wirbelt auch die flammen auf die
feuerwehrleute sind machtlos und müssen
sich in sicherheit bringen
da entwickelt sich ein feuerwerk der
diese brennenden büschel überall in die
gegend schleudert
wenn man so einen abkriegt verbrennt man
sich im schlimmsten fall könnte man
sogar sterben
staub teufel sind häufig in
wüstenlandschaften zu finden da dort
besondere klimatische bedingungen
herrschen
wenn die sonne den boden erhitzt steigt
die warme luft auf durch windböen kann
diese aufsteigende luft solle anfangen
zu rotieren und staub aufnehmen
in unserem fall kam die wärme nicht von
der sonne sondern von dem feuer
der staub teufel entfernt sich und löst
sich schließlich auf niemand wird
verletzt und es entsteht kein schaden
aber der luftwirbel hat dafür gesorgt
dass rund 4000 zusätzliche quadratmeter
land abgebrannt sind
hier schüttet wie aus eimern wahnsinn
oktober 2012 in naples florida verfolgt
ein paar wie sich draußen ein unwetter
zusammenbraut
viele leute lügen es gewitter zu
beobachten warum auch nicht sie sind ja
auch faszinierend anzusehen der viele
regen und der wind das findet offenbar
auch diese person hier
achtet auf den baum gleich wird es
mächtig windig
sie ist mit der kamera zur rechten zeit
am rechten ort sieht aus als bekäme der
baum ordentlich eine gewischt
er explodiert förmlich nicht vergessen
ein blitz kann bis zu 30.000 grad
celsius heiß sein bei dieser hitze gibt
es eine heftige explosion
aber das beste ist der hund der da wie
angenagelt stehen bleibt
[Musik]
was man in dem video nicht sieht ist die
enormen ladung die sich am herd boden
sowie im unteren teil einer wolke
aufbaut
diese ladungen wachsen einander
sozusagen entgegen und schließlich
entlädt sich die spannung aus der wolke
in einem blitz richtung erde
als das unwetter nachlässt begutachtet
das paar die schäden am einschlagsort
man sieht die blitz spur am baum dort
wurde die rinde wahrscheinlich
weggesprengt
wenn ein blitz in einen baum ein schlägt
kann es zu einer explosion kommen die
extreme hitze bringt das wasser im stamm
zum kochen und lässt es abrupt
verdampfen dadurch platzen zellen im
holz was teile der rinde förmlich ab
sprengt die elektrizität fließt durch
die wurzeln in den boden was diese
wurzeln berührt wird auch unter strom
gesetzt diese garten lampe war wohl zu
nah an den wurzeln sie ist geschmolzen
elektrizität kann enorme hitze
entwickeln
der kontakt mit der garten lampe führte
zu dem riesigen feuerball der in der
aufnahme zu sehen ist die fassung ist
abgesprengt die drähte sind völlig
verschmort
[Musik]
wie gut kennen sie sich mit blitzen aus
dank der beschaffenheit moderner
flugzeuge sind die passagiere vor
blitzen geschützt wie in diesen beiden
maschinen die über dem flughafen von
seattle tacoma vom blitz getroffen
wurden
der rumpf des flugzeugs besteht
größtenteils aus aluminium und leitet
den strom über die außenhülle weiter
die treibstofftanks haben zusätzlich
eine eingebaute blitzschlag sicherung
und jegliche elektronik an bord ist mit
einem überspannungsschutz versehen
[Musik]
dieser beeindruckenden blick auf chicago
wird gleich noch spektakulärer im juni
2010 filmt ein mann wie sich ein
unwetter über der stadt zusammenbraut
als plötzlich drei der größten gebäude
in der skyline
gleichzeitig von blitzen getroffen
werden
man sieht nicht nur den sitz kanal
sondern auch all die kleinen verästelung
es ist ein überwältigendes bild viele
fotografen leben genau für solche
aufnahmen
[Musik]
solche gebäude werden bei jedem gewitter
vom blitz getroffen also sind sie
entsprechende ausgelegt sehen sie die
spitzen dinge auf den dächern das sind
die blitzableiter sie geben dem blitz
einen bequemen kontaktpunkt über den er
das ganze gebäude hinunter und tief in
die erde fließen kann anstatt also ins
gebäude einzudringen oder
wasseranschlüsse darin zum kochen zu
bringen und explosionen hervorzurufen
wird er in den boden abgeleitet
so ist das mit uns meteorologen wenn das
wetter schlecht ist und man lieber
drinnen bleiben sollte zieht es uns nach
draußen das hätte ich liebend gern mit
eigenen augen gesehen
es gibt immer neues zu entdecken und zu
lernen diese faszination hört niemals
auf denn das wetter ist immer wieder
anders jeden tag